The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM:
Well, last time we
had discussed, in a very
general way, the field
of digital signal
processing, and hopefully
one of the things that
you were convinced of
was the importance of
this set of techniques
in a general sense.
What we'd like to
begin on now is
a discussion of some of the
details of digital signal
processing.
And in particular,
in this lecture,
I would like to introduce the
class of discrete time signals,
and also the class of
discrete time systems.
Well, last time, I
reminded you that I
will be assuming a familiarity
with continuous time signals
and systems.
And what you'll see as we
go through this lecture--
and in fact, as we go through
all of these lectures--
is a very strong similarity
between the results that you're
familiar with in the
continuous time case,
and results that will develop
for the discrete time case.
Obviously, of course, there
will also be some differences.
And these differences
are important,
and they will be
important to focus on.
So there will be a great
deal of similarity, also
a few differences.
And these few differences
are very important.
In the discrete
time domain, we're
concerned with processing
signals that are sequences.
That is, these signals are
functions of an integer
variable, which we'll call n.
Typically, will depict
sequences graphically,
as I've illustrated here on
this first viewgraph, where I've
denoted a general sequence--
which I call x of n--
a function of the
energy variable
n, and the sequence values,
I've represented by a bar graph
with the height of
each bar corresponding
to the sequence value.
So we have, then,
for example, at n
equals 0, a line of
height x of 0 at n
equals 1 a line of
height x of 1, et cetera.
Of course, as I've drawn
this horizontal axis,
I've drawn it as
a continuous line,
but it's important to keep in
mind that the sequences only
are defined--
or only make sense--
for integer values
of the argument.
If n is an integer,
then x of n makes sense.
If n is not an integer,
it's not just that x of n
is 0 or something like that,
it's simply that x of n
is not defined.
In other words, x
of n makes sense,
or is defined for n an integer,
and does not make sense,
or is not defined, if
n is not an integer.
So this, then, is a
graphical representation
of a general sequence.
And just as in the
continuous time case,
we have a number of
important basic sequences
that we would like to focus on.
The first of these that
I'd like to introduce
is the unit sample,
or impulse sequence,
which we'll denote
by delta of n.
The unit sample
sequence is a sequence
whose value is unity at n
equals 0, and it's equal to 0
otherwise.
That is delta of n equals 1
at n equals 0, and delta of n
is equal to 0 for
n not equal to 0.
The unit sample sequence
plays the same role
in the discrete time case
that the unit impulse time
function plays in the
continuous time case.
Let me just mention, however,
that the unit sample sequence
is very easily defined.
There's no issue here
about the definition.
In contrast with the usual
mathematical problems
with a continuous time impulse--
which is infinitely big at the
origin, and 0 every place else,
but has some area, et cetera.
So there's a very precise
definition here of the unit
sample, or unit
impulse sequence,
and it will play a role similar
to the unit impulse time
function in the
continuous time case.
Another important basic sequence
is the unit step sequence,
which I'm denoting by u of n.
And the unit step sequence
is equal to unity for n
greater than or equal
to 0, and is equal to 0
for n less than 0.
So the unit step sequence,
then, is 0 for n less than 0,
it's unity four n greater
than or equal to 0.
This shouldn't be, incidentally,
less than or equal to 0,
this should be n less than 0.
And it is-- again, does not have
the difficulties in definition
that a continuous time
unit step normally has.
It's the change in value
from n equals minus 1 to n
equals 0 is precisely
and easily defined.
Here the unit step is 0,
here the unit step is 1.
There's no issue, as there is
in the continuous time case,
about discontinuity.
Just as in the
continuous time case,
there is a simple relationship
between the unit sample,
or a unit impulse,
and the unit step.
In a discrete time
case, there is likewise
a simple relationship between
the unit sample sequence,
and the unit step sequence.
In particular, the
unit sample sequence
can be obtained from
the unit step sequence
by constructing the
first difference.
The unit sample
sequence, delta of n,
is equal to u of
n, the unit step,
minus the unit step
delayed by 1 sample.
And we can see
that that obviously
is the case, if we look at the
unit step sequence, u of n.
Here we have the unit step
sequence delayed by 1--
so this occurs at n equals
0, this is n equals 1.
And clearly, the difference
between those two
will generate a sample at
n equals 0, 0, of course,
for n less than 0, and 0,
likewise, for n greater than 0,
because these sequence
values will be canceled out
by those sequence values.
So the unit sample sequence is
the unit step minus the delayed
unit step, or the
unit sample sequence
is equal to the first difference
of the unit step sequence.
Similarly, we can obtain
the unit step sequence
from the unit sample sequence
by constructing a running sum.
In particular, the
unit step sequence
is equal to a running sum
of the unit sample sequence.
In other words, we're
constructing here a sum
from k equals minus infinity
to the independent variable n
of the sequence, delta of k.
Here we have the
sequence, delta of k.
If n is less than 0, then
we're adding up sequence values
from minus infinity to
some negative value of k.
And the only values
that we collect when we
do that are values equal to 0.
So for n less than 0, we see
that we obtain 0 for this sum.
If n is greater than 0, as I've
indicated here, then the sum,
as we collect sequence values
from minus infinity up to n,
we collect 1 non-0 sequence
value which is equal to 1.
Consequently for
n greater than 0,
we obtain, in this running
sum, u of n equal to 1.
This plays a role,
this running sum
plays a role, similar to the
integral in the continuous time
case.
And so now we have
a relationship
between the unit
sample sequence,
and the unit step sequence.
There are other
basic sequences that
will play an important
role, just as they
do in the continuous time case.
In particular, we have the
real exponential sequence.
The sequence x of n is
equal to alpha to the n.
I've depicted the
exponential sequence here
for the case in which alpha is
positive but less than unity,
so that as n increases,
the exponential decreases.
So alpha to the n, if
alpha is between 0 and 1,
decreases with increasing n.
If alpha is greater than 1,
then the exponential sequence
grows, of course, exponentially.
We have, also, the
sinusoidal sequence.
The general form of
the sinusoidal sequence
is x of n is equal to a
cosine omega 0 n plus phi--
phi a phase angle, omega 0 we'll
refer to as the frequency, a,
of course, is the amplitude.
I've illustrated a
sinusoidal sequence here
for a particular
choice of omega 0
and phi, namely omega
0 equal to pi over 4,
and phi equal minus pi over 8.
And in looking at this, we see
that we get a periodic sequence
that is, for this
choice of parameters,
this sequence is periodic.
However, an
important distinction
between the continuous time
case and the discrete time case,
is that a discrete time
sinusoidal signal is not
necessarily periodic.
Particular, I've
illustrated here
another sinusoidal sequence
with a different choice
for omega 0 and phi.
In this case, omega 0
equal to 3 pi over 7.
With that choice
of omega 0, these
are the sequence
values we obtain.
And it should be obvious
by examining this sequence
that this sequence is
no longer periodic,
whereas this sequence was.
So the sinusoidal sequence
may or may not be periodic.
Of course, let me remind you
that if n was allowed to vary
continuously-- if it was
not an integer variable--
x of n would be periodic.
The periodicity is lost
because n is now constrained
to be an integer variable.
And that is one of the
important distinctions
between continuous time signals
and systems, and discrete time
signals and systems.
Another point which
I'll suggest now,
although it's a point
that I'll want to refer to
in more detail in some
of the future lectures,
is that the sinusoidal sequence
is only distinguishable
as omega 0 runs from
over the range 0 to 2 pi
or minus pi to pi.
If omega 0-- if we were to
replace omega 0 by omega 0
plus 2 pi, then we would have
in this argument omega 0 n plus
2 pi n.
The 2 pi n, of course,
would have no effect,
and we'd end up with
the same sequence.
So in fact as, we varied omega
0 between minus pi and plus pi,
you will have seen all of
the sinusoidal sequences
with this amplitude
and this phase
that we can possibly generate.
One of the important of
this set of basic signals
is that they can be used to
represent a more general class
of signals, just as in
the continuous time case,
we use impulses, or we
use complex exponentials,
or we use sinusoids to
represent very general signals,
we can develop similar
representations here.
Let me illustrate this
with an example where
I consider a general
sequence here, x of n.
The sequence values are x of
0, x of 1, x of 2, et cetera.
And I mean to suggest here
a very general sequence.
Now, I can decompose
this sequence
into a linear combination
of weighted, delayed unit
samples, unit sample
sequences, by simply
extracting individual
sequence values out of x of n.
For example, let's
consider the sequence
x of 0 times delta of n,
as I've illustrated here.
X of 0 times delta of n is
equal to the original sequence
x of n at n equals 0, and
it's equal to 0 otherwise.
A second sequence, x of 1
times delta of n minus 1,
is a unit sample
sequence, delayed by 1
and having an amplitude
equal to x of 1.
So this sequence is equal
to this one at n equals 1,
and it's equal to 0, otherwise.
The sum of these
two, of course, is
equal to this x of n at these
two values, and equal to 0,
otherwise.
Similarly, we can consider
x of minus 1 times
delta of n plus 1.
That's a unit sample
at n equals minus 1,
with an amplitude
of x of minus 1,
which picks up this
sequence value.
x of minus 2 times delta of n
plus 2 is a unit sample at n
equals minus 2 multiplied by
an amplitude x of minus 2,
which picks up this
sequence value, et cetera.
So I think you can see, then,
that as we add these up,
what we'll generate is this
arbitrary sequence, x of n.
In other words, we can construct
x of n, an arbitrary sequence,
as a linear combination of
weighted delayed unit samples--
x of 0 times delta of n plus x
of 1 times delta of n minus 1
plus x of minus 1 delta
n plus 1, et cetera.
Or, more generally,
the sum from k
equals minus infinity to
plus infinity of x of k times
delta of n minus k.
This, then, corresponds to
a general representation
of an arbitrary sequence in
terms of weighted delayed unit
samples.
And it's a representation that
we'll want to refer back to
in a few minutes.
It's not, as I've indicated,
the only representation
of arbitrary sequences--
we'll also be developing
representations
in terms of complex
exponentials,
or real exponentials, or in
terms of sines and cosines.
OK, that is an introduction
to the basic class of signals
and the notion of sequences.
What I'd like to do now is focus
on the class of discrete time
systems, and then refer back
to some of these results
to develop a general
representation
for a special class of
discrete time systems.
First of all, let me begin
with a general system, which
is a discrete time system
that has an input--
which is a sequence x of n.
It has an output, which
is a sequence y of n.
And it has a system
transformation,
which I've denoted by T.
Of course, there isn't much
that you can do with
a general system--
the difficulty with trying
to describe a general system
in general is that
there are no properties
that you can take advantage of.
So always, in
characterizing systems,
it's useful to specialize
the class of systems--
that is, impose properties
on the system which
you can exploit to
represent the system,
or to implement the
system, et cetera.
The special class that
we'll want to consider
is the class of systems which
are, first of all, linear.
And second of all,
shift invariant.
And this class corresponds,
in the continuous time case,
to the class of systems
that we normally
refer to as linear
and time invariant.
We'll tend to refer to these
as linear and shift invariant,
and for a shorthand notation,
just express this as well LSI.
When I refer to an LSI
system, what I mean
is a system that is linear
and shift invariant.
Well, let's define these terms.
First of all, linearity.
Linearity states
that if I excite
the system with a sequence x 1
of n, and I get at the output
a sequence y 1 of n, and
if I excite with x 2 of n,
and get at the output y 2 of n,
then the condition of linearity
is that the linear combination,
a x 1 of n plus b x 2 of n,
produces at the output a
y1 of n plus b y 2 of n.
That is, the response of the
system to a sum of inputs,
or a linear
combination of inputs,
is a linear combination of
the corresponding outputs.
Now, by repeated application
of just this statement,
we can make a more
general statement,
which is that the sum of a sub
k times x sub k of n produces,
as an output, the sum of a
sub k times y sub k of n.
Linearity is stated here,
of course, for two inputs,
but we can obviously extend
that to an arbitrary number
of inputs so that the statement
of linearity, as we'll
refer to it, will
generally be that
a general linear combination of
inputs produces, at the output,
the same linear combination
of the corresponding outputs.
So that's the
condition of linearity.
The second condition
that we want
to impose on our
class of systems
is the condition of
shift invariance.
What shift invariance says,
simply, is that if x of n
produces y of n,
then x of n minus n 0
produces y of n minus n 0.
It's basically a statement that
the system doesn't particularly
care what you call n equals 0.
In other words, if we
shift the input in n,
we shift the output in n.
It's exactly like the
condition of time invariance
in the continuous time case.
For example, if we excited
the system with a unit sample,
to get the unit
sample response, h
of n, then the response of the
system, if the system is shift
invariant, to a
delayed unit sample
is the delayed version of
the unit sample response.
So this is shift invariance.
We had the condition
of linearity.
These are two
independent conditions
which we'll now
want to put together
to develop a general
representation for linear shift
invariant systems.
Well, let me remind you
from the last viewgraph
that we had looked at, that we
had a general representation
for a sequence in terms of
weighted delayed units samples.
That is, previously we had
developed a representation,
x of n, of this form, which
expresses an arbitrary
sequence in terms of weighted
delayed unit samples.
Well, this, then,
says that x of n
is expressed as a linear
combination of basic inputs,
and if we restrict
ourselves to linear systems,
then the output must correspond
to the same linear combination
of the corresponding outputs.
Well, delta of n minus k into
a linear shift invariant system
will produce, at the
output, by virtue
of the property of shift
invariance, the sequence
h of n minus k.
And the linear combination
of these delayed unit
samples will produce at the
output, by virtue of linearity,
the same linear combination
of the responses
to delta of n minus k.
So if we consider a linear shift
invariant system, and because
of this representation,
we can say
that the response due
to an arbitrary input
is equal to a linear combination
of delayed unit sample
responses.
Where, in general,
this is a sum from k
equals minus infinity
to plus infinity.
Well, this is the key result--
this is a statement
that says that if we
talk about linear shift
invariant systems,
then all that we need
to know about the system
to characterize it is its
response to a unit sample.
If we have its response
to a unit sample,
we can construct y
of n in general--
that is, we can construct
the output for an arbitrary
input, x of k.
This is generally referred
to as the convolution sum.
In analogy with the convolution
integral in the continuous time
case, this is one way of
writing the convolution sum.
There is an
alternative, which is
interesting in that it suggests
some important properties
of linear shift
invariant systems,
and it's obtained
simply by applying
a substitution of variables
to this expression.
In particular, suppose
that we replace n minus k
by the variable r,
or equivalently, k
is equal to n minus r.
Then what we obtain is y of
n is now equal to a sum--
and this is now a sum on r.
For k, we have n minus r.
So this is x of
n minus r times h
of n minus k, which
is equal to r.
So this h of r.
Well, it's a simple
step to take,
but in fact, what it says
is that the system doesn't
particularly care what you
call the input to the system,
and what you call the unit
sample response of the system.
Said another way, it says that
convolution is commutative--
that is, if we represent
the convolution of x of n
with h of n with
an asterisk, then,
because of the fact that
we were able to interchange
the roles of x of n and
h of n, that implies,
essentially, that x of
n convolved with h o n
is the same thing as h of
n convolved with x of n.
That implies, as I
indicated, that if we
had a system with an impulse
response or unit sample
response, h of n, and input
x of n, and output y of n,
that if I call this the input,
and I call this the unit sample
response--
as I've done here--
we obtain the same output.
That is, h of n into a system
with unit sample response, x
of n, gives us at the
output, y of n, also.
An implication of that is that
linear shift invariant systems
in cascade don't
particularly care which order
the systems are cascaded in.
That is, if I have
a system h 1 of n--
that is with unit sample
response, h 1 of n--
and cascade with a system with
unit sample response h 2 of n,
and input x of n,
the unit sample
response of this
overall system is h 1
of n convolved with h 2 of n.
But since convolution
is commutative,
we could just as easily
convolve h 2 with h 1,
and that corresponds to a
cascade of the system h 2 of n
with the system h 1 of n.
So simply because of the
fact that convolution
is commutative, that
implies that, for example,
that linear shift invariant
systems in cascade
don't particularly care in
which order their cascaded.
There are lots of other
properties of convolution
and simple properties of
linear shift invariant systems
that are a direct
consequence of convolution,
and some of the properties that
we've mentioned of convolution.
And a number of these, we'll see
in the lectures as we go along,
and also a number of
them you'll have a chance
to wrestle with in
the study guide.
OK, so this is a development
of the convolution sum.
One of the important aspects
of the convolution sum
is the steps involved in
actually computing it--
that is, the manipulations
involved in forming this sum.
And as the last point that I'd
like to make in this lecture,
I'd like to illustrate, first
with a viewgraph, and then
with a movie, the computation,
or the implementation,
of the convolution sum.
So let's return
to the viewgraph.
And I've indicated here,
again, the convolution sum as--
we've derived it-- y of n is the
sum of x of k h of n minus k.
Now, in implementing
the convolution sum,
let me stress that
it is for n, which
is the independent
variable for which
we are computing the output--
that is, k is just
simply a dummy variable
inside this summation.
Well, I've illustrated here, for
a specific example, a sequence,
x of k, which is a
constant from 0 to I
guess n equals 10, equal to
unity for n equals 0 to 10,
and 0 otherwise.
And I've indicated the sequence
a little differently here than
I had previously, since I
want to distinguish between
the x's, h's, and the y's.
The sequence x of k, I'm
denoting with little x's--
the sequence h, I'll denote
note with little h's, and later
on, the sequence y, we'll
denote with little y's.
All right, so here we have the
sequence a, that's this one.
And plotted as a function of k.
Here, I have the
sequence, h of k,
which I've chosen to
be an exponential for k
greater than 0, and
0 for k less than 0.
But it's not h of k that
we want in this sum.
It's h of n minus k.
And what's n?
Well, n is whatever value
of the output sequence
we're trying to compute.
So if n was equal
to 0, for example,
we would want the
sequence, h of 0 minus k.
And that's this sequence.
It's h of k, flipped around in
k, because of this minus sign,
and not shifted one
way or the other
simply because we have a 0 here.
So here's h of k, but
that's not what you want.
It's h of 0 minus k.
And now to compute y of 0, we
would multiply this sequence
by this one, and compute
the sum from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
That would give us
the value, y of 0.
For a different
value of n, we would
have to look at h of n minus
k, for whichever value of n
we were computing this for.
For example, if n
is equal to minus 4,
the sequence that we want
is h of minus 4 minus k,
and that is this sequence
shifted to the left by 4.
So to compute y of
minus 4, we want
this sequence
multiplied by this one,
and the sum computed from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
And you can see, obviously,
for that particular case--
that is n equal to minus 4--
the product of
this and this is 0,
and the sum will be equal to 0.
Well, let's look at this example
a little more dynamically,
with a movie that was prepared
at Bell Telephone Laboratories
by Dr. Ronald Shaefer.
OK, the convolution
sum, then, we
have is the sum of x
of k, h of n minus k.
And so what we would
like to illustrate
is the operation of
evaluating this sum.
On the top, we have x of k.
On the bottom we have h of k--
he of k being an exponential.
And now, we see h of minus k,
namely h of k flipped over.
As we shift h of k to the
left, corresponding to n
equals minus 1, then back
to 0, and now to the right.
So we have h of 1 minus k.
And then to 4 y of n, we want
the product of h of minus k
shifted with x of
k, that product sum
from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
So here, we see x of k
times h of 1 minus k, 2
minus k, 3 minus k, et cetera.
Those multiplied and then
summed from minus infinity
to plus infinity, we
see during this portion
that more and more
values of h are
engaged with non-0 values
of x, and so y of n
grows until we reach the
point where values fall off
the end of the non-0 values
of x, where y of n decays.
So this, then, is
an illustration
of the linear convolution
of x of k with h of k.
OK, this completes
our introduction
to discrete time
signals and systems.
There were a number
of important points
that we've made
during this lecture.
But the key result,
and the result
that it's important to
develop some experience with,
is the convolution sum.
Next time, we'll introduce
some additional considerations,
namely the considerations
of stability and causality
for discrete time systems.
And we'll also discuss, briefly,
the class of linear shift
invariant systems
that are represented
by linear constant coefficient
difference equations.
Finally, we'll try to
tie some of this together
and in particular, present what
will be called the frequency
response of the systems.
And this will eventually
lead into a discussion
of Fourier transforms.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]